120 tage krieg und unser reporter paul
ronzheimer derzeit den seit beginn
dieses kriegs jeden tag diesen krieg in
der ukraine wir haben ihnen über seine
gefährliche reise in den donna sind die
ost ukraine berichtet wo paul und sein
team beschossen worden sind sie waren
dorthin gereist um uns die lage der
ganzen welt die lage in lizenz zu zeigen
diesem ort dieser stadt der so sehr
umkämpftes umstellte eingekesselt ist
von den russen oh das ist pauls
reportage
der don was im süden der ukraine
hier tobt der krieg mit unverminderter
härte trotz ukrainischer gegenwehr
denken die russen nicht an rückzug die
frontlinie war bat jeden tag ein paar
meter vor und zurück wir sind doch nicht
der ort der von den großen eingekesselt
wird
[Musik]
immer wieder angefangen die straße zur
hölle wie sie unter ukraine genannt wird
ist der einzige weg in das fast
eingekesselte
[Musik]
distanz der stadt in lugansk region die
fast komplett von den russen
eingekesselt es hinter mir das völlig
zerstörte kulturzentrum konstante
bombardierungen wie menschen leben nur
noch im keller kaum menschen sind
geblieben von dieser 100.000 einwohner
stadt ein paar tausend die noch hier
sind und die lage für die menschen in
dieser stadt des dramatisch
[Musik]
plötzlich wie ein geist taucht ein alter
mann in den ruinen auf es ist wladimir
als junger mann war er hier der
filmvorführer
was haben sie hier in der letzten zeit
erlebt
so wurde ich lebe hier seit 73 jahren es
war eine rakete die von da drüben kam
und hier einschlug niemanden hat es
gestört nicht einmal die feuerwehr es
gekommen das dach hat angefangen zu
brennen und dann hat sich der brand
ausgebreitet bis das ganze gebäude
zusammengebrochen ist das ist ein stalin
bau von 1953
wie überleben sie hier da hingehe ich
habe weder wasser noch lebensmittel ich
habe hunger sowie 1941
warum verlassen sie die stadt nicht
wo sollte ich hingehen wer braucht mich
geld habe ich auch keine
ein geist des krieges menschen sind auf
den straßen von diese chance nicht zu
sehen
paul ronzheimer trifft auf georgi er ist
priester der ukrainischen orthodoxen
kirche versteckt sich mit mitgliedern
seiner gemeinde in einem keller
roger prüfung seiner person
die situation ist sehr angespannt aber
unsere tapfere armee versucht die stadt
zu verteidigen sie tut alles was möglich
ist unsere polizei hilft bei der
beschaffung von wasser und lebensmitteln
und versucht die ordnung
aufrechtzuerhalten
wir sind unserer polizei sehr dankbar
was tun sie wenn die stadt fällt
ich werde für den frieden beten und
hoffen dass sie den leuten hier nichts
böses antun und die gesetze gottes
befolgen
zusammen mit mitgliedern seiner gemeinde
versteckt sich georgi in einem keller
gerade versorgen ihn helfer mit
lebensmittelrationen
wir sind in einem der vielen keller von
distanz wo die menschen tag und nacht
ausharren weil die bomben so heftig sind
gerade in den vergangenen tagen ist es
extrem geworden weil die russischen
soldaten teilweise nur wenige kilometer
in ihren frontstellungen sind dann die
menschen trauen sich kaum noch aus nur
wenn es mal ganz kurz ruhig ist gerade
sind hier helfer gekommen die
nahrungsmittel gebracht haben aber die
sorge ist groß dass auch das bald nicht
mehr möglich ist wasser bekommen die
verbliebenen einwohner von dc chance nur
noch wenn es gebracht wird längst sind
alle leitungen der stadt tot
die menschen in russland sind seit vier
monaten ohne wasser und hier ist die
letzte möglichkeit werden man das
grollen im hintergrund in dieser stadt
hört der letzte check point wurde
bereits getroffen vor der stadt
wissenschafts droht zu fallen
warum gehen sie nicht weg von hier die
stadt bombardiert
sie haben drei tage lang leute evakuiert
und dann gesagt helft euch selbst ich
weiß nicht was ich tun soll wie soll ich
von ihr weg um wieder zurück zu kommen
braucht man auch geld das ist meine
heimat warum sollte ich sie verraten in
kiew packen sie einfach die sachen und
gehen aber wir gehen nirgends hin wir
bleiben zu hause
verzweiflung zerstörung das angesicht
des krieges in liesing um aus der stadt
zu kommen müssen paul ronzheimer und
sein team erneut die straße zur hölle
benutzen erst vor zwei wochen ist hier
ein französischer reporter ums leben
gekommen plötzlich explosionen
das muss höchstens 100 oder 150 meter
weit weg gewesen sein in den feldern
gerade
ins auto erschossen worden richtung
straße ist wahrscheinlich die
gefährlichste
ukraine gerade gibt so schnell wie
möglich rast das bild team über eine
staubige straße versucht den explosionen
zu entkommen das ist sie die straße zur
hölle
das auto wird getroffen eine scheibe
geht zu bruch nur
erwischt worden ist
die russen schießen hier diesen weg weil
das der einzige weg raus ist aus der
stadt
erst nach gut einer halben stunde fahrt
kann das bild team die straße zur hölle
verlassen sind die explosionen nicht
mehr zu hören wie durch ein wunder wird
niemand verletzt
[Musik]
und inzwischen dass paul daraus und
möglicherweise in der nächsten halle
dort in kharkiv grüße dich paul das ist
die zweitgrößte stadt der ukraine
eigentlich eine junge stadt wie wir
gelernt haben mit diesem krieg eine
kulturstadt aber eine stadt die wirklich
vom ersten kriegstag an brutal
bombardiert worden ist wie sieht diese
stadt jetzt aus nach 120 tagen krieg
ja es hat eine kurze entspannungsphase
gegeben in den vergangenen wochen oder
vergangenen 12 wochen aber jetzt haben
wir gerade wieder massiven alarm gehört
und auch in der nacht gab es beschuss
explosion einschläge also die sorge hier
in kharkiv in dieser großstadt ist groß
dass die russen wieder nahe kommen
können ich gehe es darum die moral der
menschen also wir haben eine zeit
gesehen du hast diese entspannungsphase
angesprochen wo unsere reporter gefilmt
haben wie aufgeräumt wurde wie
trümmerteile beseitigt worden wie man
versucht hat wieder ein bisschen zu
leben und jetzt nimmt eben der beschuss
wieder zu also wie steht es um die moral
ist eine große verunsicherung
am anfang war es so dass man gehofft
hatte dass aktiv so werden würde wieder
wie kiew wo es wieder normal wurde und
auf den autos die auf den straßen autos
waren aber das ist hier nicht zu
erkennen wenig leute auf der straße aber
die leute die wir bislang getroffen
haben die sagen alle wir verteidigen
diese stadt wir bleiben hier und vor
allem versuchen sie die russischen
truppen soweit abzuschneiden wieder dass
die artillerie diese gefährliche
tödliche artillerie hier nicht mehr in
das stadtzentrum treffen kann